foreign
welcome back to Boom talk today teaching
myself to make a homemade blasting cap
if this works it'll be step one in
making our own improvised explosive
might be headed to Texas for the winter
once in Texas
this project
what kind of project
I'm gonna stop the pipeline from being
built on my property poisons here water
oh
damn this place is sick you guys cooking
meth in here you ready to start working
show how vulnerable the oil industry is
by hitting something big
Michael what do you think the odd diary
blow yourself up
[Music]
I don't really care
we could blow the pipe at the hilltop
keep the awe from leaking
you're not actually thinking I'm not
thinking about it I'm doing it
what if y'all do structural damage
structural damage is kind of the point
this is destruction of federal property
terrorism
American Empire calls us terrorists then
we're doing something right
there
let the properties will be trashed three
two one
and claim this was violence
vandalism
this was justified
[Music]
this was an act of self-defense